لا اعلن الجيش الكوري والجنوبي ان كوريا
الشماليه يتقاص صاروخان ماليستيا قصيره
المدى قبلت سواحلها شرقيه وان سول في
وضعيه الاستعداد الكامل بالتعاون الوثيقي
مع الولايات المتحده وعقل الجيش الكوري
الجنوبي ان الصاروخ الذي اطلقته بيونجا
حلقا على ارتفاع 47 كلم ولمسافه 200 240
كم اعلن الجيش الجنوبي اجراء قوته تدريبات
لانظمه الدفاع الصاروخيه مع القوات
الامريكيه بعد تجربه صاروخيه كما قال ان
تجربه صاروخيه استفزاز خطير يضر بالسلام
والاستقرار في المنطقه من جهتها نقلت
وكاله الانباء الكوريه الشماليه عن وزير
الخارجيه توعوده بان تزداد ردود بلاده حده
على تدريبات العسكريه المشتركه بين كوريا
الجنوبيه والولايات المتحده واتهم وزير
الخارجيه هي الكوريه الشمالي واشنطن وصول
بتعميق الامنيه في المنطقه وبجرها الى وضع
يصعب التنبؤ بعواقبه وفقوله